Allah subhana WA Ta'ala says no Quran
audhu billahi min ash-shaytani r-rajim
fearful is somehow our team and I'll
give up Tina I feel a me when dieting
the only land
Aladin al-quran happy
called Anwar Jun will be him
while Arjun o being wet effect on a
fearfully somehow our team well jalapeno
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala says surely in
the creation of the heavens in the earth
and in the alternation of the night and
day
there are signs for those who believe
the ones who remember Allah p.m. and
Waka olden standing and sitting were a
legend will be him and on their sides
and they think about the creation of
allah subhanahu wata'ala saying to
themselves you haven't created this
creation in falsehood glory be to you so
protect us from the Hellfire Subhan
Allah Allah subhana WA Ta'ala ya know
for those who are going to reflect and
say that there is no way that you have
created all this in vain it's impossible
we are here today where we came for with
some youngsters to do some hiking and
it's absolutely amazing when we live in
the cities we see TV telephone cars
buildings and we do not get the chance
to get to conscious such places and look
around us be it the water behind us as
you can see look look at that look at
the mountains look around you we are
seeing little lizards that are running
around and subhanAllah for those who
have intellect for those who truly think
what lie this is a sign it can be
anything it can't be anything else and
one of the sisters we wanted to share
this reminder with you guys because
Alice wants Allah says indeed remind the
benefits a believer and what lie we hope
that as you see this and look at this
and reflect yourself and know and say
what lie there is no other way there is
no way that all of this is just created
just for the sake of it
allah subhanaw taala also says in the
quran you know this is a beautiful area
and the end of sources of silla chapter
41 of the quran where our lost parent
analysis january him ayah Tina
EFE
forcing hatate by jana Lihue man
that will certainly show them our signs
in the horizons and in themselves so
that they may know certainly that this
is the truth and is it not enough for
you that Allah is over all things a
witness so subhanAllah it's really
amazing to find that allah subhanho wa
taala it doesn't just it doesn't just
expect you to believe in that kind of
owning pseudo-intellectual way it's
living signs that you see and you can
physically interact with and that you
can come to a conclusion by looking at
the signs of allah so allah tala that
this is the truth it must have come from
the all-knowing the all-powerful
allah exactly and i just want to wrap up
with something that will recite on a
daily basis al hamdu lillahi rabbil
alameen and i think to myself if i lad
didn't you tell us
now you need to recite this actually
what like how could you hold yourself
walking through nature and off seat
yourself handle it line up ilana me or
praises belong to the one who's crated
heavens in the earth yani you will not
help but say this on your tongue because
it's amazing it's absolutely amazing and
what lie it's the Huq al hamdulillah
uphill al-amin or praises belong to
allah who's created the heavens and the
earth the whole universe and that's why
we say a yak and nabudu wa iyyaka
nastain because surely and truly once
you walk around and look and say all
praises belong to you of course this
next thing is going to be the action
here you alone we worship and you alone
we ask for help because once you see
this creation and it hits the heart what
lie you can't help but prostrate to your
Lord and it is true and it's the hug
that you are known we worship our Lord
and you alone we ask for help and that's
it may Allah bless you guys insha'Allah
hopefully this has maybe I would say
share this with your friends whoever it
may be you know we're not here giving
intellectual argument this cannot put
that too aside for now so sometimes you
just have to say you know what just
reflect saruman a cantilever head